ja auch ihre schwester patricia hat sich
dazu geäußert wir wollen einmal kurz
gemeinsam rein hören ist für uns nichts
neues anschluss hat schon von halbes
jahr angekündigt dass er geht wir
wünschen dir eben auch viel erfolgende
seine projekte und er ist jederzeit
herzlich willkommen zurück zu der kelly
family
wir machen weiter wir haben große pläne
und wir haben große lust und es war eine
unfassbare zeit letzten drei jahren 99
konzerte arenen shows ausverkauft in
sieben länder europas also der wahnsinn
und wir machen weiter und wir freuen uns
sehr auf die fans aber erstmal eine
kleine urlaub wir brauchen eine pause
ein kleiner urlaub und ja und dann geht
es weiter